at its Inception Cloud run was ideal for
web services but industries of all kinds
wanted that same serverless experience
write code let the platform scale and do
the rest for all workloads not just web
serving that's why we're building a top
this model and moving serverless forward
in Cloud run with a couple of new
features we now can support workloads
like data Transformations database
migrations even workloads that need
Network file system access the first is
cloud run jobs this allows you to bring
containers with long run to completion
jobs no need to hack around HTP requests
and rewrite code the second is a second
generation of our Cloud run execution
environment this environment provides
faster CPU and network performance to
intensive workloads that need it and
lets you mount Network file systems it
even brings full compatibility with all
Linux features if you want to be
notified of what the cloud run team
comes up with next be sure to like And
subscribe to the Google Cloud Tech
channel for future updates